there's only one thing
nancy loves more than gelato lawyers
in a year when we ask millions of
americans to unite and fight a novel
virus nancy pelosi's instinct
is to protect the lawyers by vowing to
block liability project protections
for employers in the next relief package
here it is
what we will not support is the
following what they're saying to
essential workers
you have to go to work because you're
essential
we've placed no responsibility on your
employer
to make that workplace safe and if you
get sick
you have no recourse because we've given
your employer protection
and if you don't go to work because
you're afraid of being sick
and you have that job opportunity you
don't get
unemployment insurance this is so unfair
so wait we placed no responsibility on
the employers to make the workplace safe
where the hell has she been hiding
underground with joe
the guy who read rip van winkle and made
it his political playbook
unless you've been refrigerated like
delicious mint chocolate chip
for seven months you've seen an amazing
commitment to ensure safety
so let's not assume people who want to
get back to work are being irresponsible
they're making adult decisions
struggling to save their livelihoods
liability protection exists to allow
civilization
enough time to restart before the
lawyers
carve up the carcass and we get it if a
business doesn't make sure
that it's safe for employees it's not
going to be safe for customers
any idiot can figure that out but
nancy's not just any idiot she's a
left-wing democrat behold into left-wing
law firms
who shovel 80 percent of their political
donations into her party's pockets
and because lawyers know they can make
billions on coveted litigation who cares
if it can keep small businesses from
returning to work ever which is why she
pivots to a desperate pot shot
let's just get to the heart of it at the
point of all of this is
this president i have a new name for him
mr
make matters worse he has made matters
worse from the start
delay denial it's a hoax it'll go away
magically it's a miracle
and all the rest and we're in this
situation
that you spelled out some of the numbers
very clearly early
so it make matters
well that was painful again let's point
out nancy
gave no practical advice on dealing with
a pandemic
she cowardly laid low and then waited to
armchair quarterback much
later if she had all the answers to the
virus
she must have kept them to herself that
makes her the real villain here
and someone who might have more than
just rum raisin on her hands
all right dana welcome back to the show
you were missed
thank you thank you i don't like rum
raisins
i is the worst ice cream of all ice
creams
it is that's why i i assume that nancy
pelosi
would be eating it because she seems
like a rum raisin type
what do you make of her um this
condition and what she's trying she's
did this before she roadblocks
these uh packages and i mean
we our obvious reply would be of course
safety is our concern we're not idiots
of course well and it's also not true
so there's that um greg was it about
eight weeks ago maybe even more
that you did a monologue based on a
washington post
article that basically listed all the
lawsuits that had happened up until then
and it had only been about six weeks
that we had been dealing with the
pandemic
so imagine between then and now how many
we have and you're about to see a lot
more
talk about think about evictions and
commercial real estate not to mention
for renters and also it's absolutely not
true you have so many small businesses
like hair salons for example they have
had to buy
and invest put money into getting the
plexiglass
organized so that they can reopen making
sure their employees have enough masks
and they've had to limit their hours for
certain employees
they don't want to be sued they don't
want as you said they don't want the
liability of somebody
something to go wrong because their
entire livelihood is wrapped up in their
business
and so this bill that mcconnell is
putting forward
does not say that a business doesn't
have to do anything to ensure safety it
says that it does
right it's specifically about frivolous
lawsuits to help protect these
businesses
and there's lots of other things in this
bill too but one thing that nancy pelosi
and the democrats did right is they
organized very early they knew that
there was going to be
another round of stimulus they set some
boundaries for what they were going to
be for
and they are holding on like red rover
red rover send that bill right over and
they'll probably reject it
and the president needs a bill so these
negotiations aren't going to be pretty
and it's going to be very
very expensive but it is an investment
that we need to make to make the economy
come back
get people whole get the schools back
open and all those things we need to do
is we try to stay healthy
and thank you for my ted talk what do
you make of it
yeah there you go i could tell you're
waiting
uh dagan what do you make of this well
if you're cynical
which i am this is a way for the
democrats to keep
unemployment above 10 or even higher
going into the november election so
here's the way it plays out
you make people more dependent on the
federal government
you deny any liability protection for
businesses so they can't bring people
back
on the job they can't hire new workers
you continue the 600 extra
per week which by the way more than
two-thirds of people on unemployment
according to the university of chicago
are making more on unemployment than
they did in their jobs
so they stay on unemployment they don't
go back to work
and then you also have no school
reopenings so all the moms out there or
even dads have to stay at home and take
care of their kids
they can't go back to work you literally
wipe out a
generation of gains in the workforce for
women
but again it benefits the democrats if
it looks like the economy
pardon my language sucks and by the way
if this is the best person the democrats
have to throw barbs at trump
this is a rich octogenarian
limousine liberal and that's the best
they've got what's she going to do hit
trump with their pocketbook next
yeah you know um speaking of the
president juan i want to play some tape
uh president trump talking about the
death rates which we don't really hear
enough about
take it away the mortality rate for
patients over the age of 18
is 85 percent lower than it was in april
think of that 85 percent
and is 25 lower than europe as a whole
so that's good news juan right
yeah i'm all for it i don't want
you know i don't want anybody to die so
that's good news
uh i think i think the you know the
counterpoint greg would be we see an
increasing
number of not only deaths but you know
coronavirus infections
but to get back to your issue about the
liability
i mean it's not uncommon for people to
have to sign waivers if they're
doing voluntary activities like if
you're going skydiving you know or if
you're
going to a trump rally in tulsa in the
midst of a cronovirus
epidemic so that's we've seen people
asked to sign those kinds of waivers the
difference here
i don't think it's so much you know
political
in except you're right it means
obviously democrats and
republicans on capitol hill he'll have a
difference but i don't think it's so
political in the sense that
you have people concerned about
activities that they have to do which is
go to work
or be a customer for a business and they
want to feel safe they want to
be sure that any business is making
every
effort to protect their well-being and i
think that what you're seeing for the
contrary point from the democrats is
you can't pass a liability waiver that
frees business
from making customer safety worker
safety
a priority they want to make sure and
that's
i think the heart and soul of what's
going on here
the contrary you know the idea that
somehow you're just letting people run
wild i think people want to go back to
work i think people want to
do business i think we're all anxious
for it but we want to be safe that's all
yeah uh jesse i think we all have gone
over the
we all want to be safe argument to a
point that like we're trying to get to
the next step now we assess
the risks and the benefits we're adults
nobody wants to get hurt i mean i would
agree with juan
on one thing that skydiving yes is as
thrilling as going to a trump rally that
was a very astute point
uh on daigan mcdowell um i'm just not as
cynical as degen
i don't think nancy pelosi would destroy
the country
just to get joe biden elected yes it
looks like that
by shutting the economy down and opening
up the borders
but i think maybe perhaps that she's
just more crooked because
she's just in the pocket of trial lawyer
lobby because that's who wins here
if businesses aren't protected then if
you test positive for covid19
you call a lawyer and then you just make
a list
of all the places you went in the last
week and then you sue your grocery store
you sue your pharmacy and you sue your
boss
and the businesses that had been
bankrupt during the pandemic
they're already gone so the only ones
that remained open then they're bankrupt
after all this mass litigation
and i can't believe to watch nancy
because i remember watching
john boehner the previous speaker
remember he used to go in these sunday
shows
and these hosts used to throw razor
blades at the guy nancy pelosi gets up
there
she's treated like angelina jolie
promoting a movie right
it's a softball situation and then
there's questions and areas
that you're not allowed to ask about and
the nickname
deal is ironic you know because she's
really the leader of the do nothing
congress they've done nothing except
impeach the president which just
distracted washington
from the pandemic and we had this great
moment in this country where we could
have had unity
where we could have fought against the
common enemy the virus and the chinese
communist party
and she just threw it all away and made
trump the enemy
and you know what like like a dad i'm
not mad
i'm disappointed
[Laughter]
all right